it's great to welcome to the program
today dr. Sophie Leroy who is associate
professor at the University of
Washington Bothell School of Business
great to speak to you today I appreciate
it
oh you're welcome it's great to be on
your show so let's just start when we
talk about the idea of multitasking does
multitasking even really exist or is it
just switching between one task and
another and working on each individually
you're right it actually does not fully
exist like a brain cannot process two
things at the same time so what we do is
actually we switch very quickly between
two things or even more so we feel like
we're multitasking when in fact we're
not we're really against switching back
and forth back and forth really really
fast
so in these tests or studies that are
sometimes done where someone is for
example driving a car on a closed course
and there are different obstacles that
pop up and they're simultaneously being
given simple or sometimes not so simple
math problems over the phone it does
seem as though you are both driving and
solving the math problems at the same
time but in some sense are you sort of
putting the driving in an autopilot mode
as you think about the math problems yes
absolutely and that's why from a
performance standpoint this is really
problematic right because what it means
is that when you do the math problem or
while you're driving you're actually not
focused on the road you're not
processing what's going on on the road
and so you can miss queues you can miss
things that are happening your your
reaction time is delayed because you
need something else to capture your
attention very you know very fast back
on the road and so when you're not also
when you're on the road and not doing
your math problem you're going to be
slower at your math problem because
you're actually not processing the mask
made so from a performance standpoint
there are many issues that comes into
play due to the fact that because we're
switching back and forth there is a very
small time period where you're actually
not doing what you're supposed to do so
when we think about how we might sort of
do our work throughout the course of a
day and there is a lot of this what some
people might call multitasking but it's
really switching between tasks back and
forth there's the term attention residue
which is an interesting
which if I understand correctly relates
to the way in which as you switch
between tasks some of your attention is
not fully there yet or is remaining on
the prior task is that more or less what
we mean when we say attention residue
that's right
and so it's a little different from the
multitasking aspect right so
multitasking you're trying to do two
things at the same time and your brain
is switching back and forth back and
forth between those two things
attention residue is a little different
in the sense where it occurs when we
work on something and then we have to
let it go in transition to something
else and in that case our brain cannot
do that either we have a part time
transitioning because we have a hard
time letting go of things that are
incomplete so tensioners does not
necessary
but it occurs when we not fully
satisfied with what we've done
it's not finished we were interrupted in
the middle of that thought process and
as we transition the brain does not want
to let go in part because we have a need
for completion and so those transitions
of those interruptions are really
frustrating our need for completion and
so the brain is going to hold on to it
process what's going on on that task
that we have to put aside and so what
happens is we have actually divided
attention our brain in fact then
multitask attention residue is a form of
multitasking in the sense that it will
go back to the task we're working on
previously and and at the same time try
to perform what we're supposed to do in
the present so it's a little different
right in terms of what triggers it but
it's very relevant to the workplace as
well because as you think about how we
work right often time we have to go from
meetings to the next we're working on a
project bullying there's a phone call
for example about a clock from a client
or someone else passing by a colleague
who needs some information and is asking
some questions right so we have to
transition very frequently and Western
systems are just very very hard for the
brain to perform so when I interviewed
Cal Newport a few weeks ago who teaches
computer science at Georgetown I believe
it is he suggests this idea of a planned
deep work right focusing on single
intense
asks for long periods of time because
you're reducing the number of those
transitions that you're referring to and
you can be most sort of productive and
thinking most deeply when you spend a
long period of time focused on one thing
of course the practical issue seems to
be that in more and more jobs 20 30 40
even more than half of the job can
basically be writing emails and
switching to meetings and taking phone
calls and those types of activities so
it seems like that is definitely the
best ideal but it seems very impractical
for many modern jobs at this point in
time absolutely in and that's actually
where my what my research focused on is
kind of assuming that we can't change
our corporate cultures that the neat
kind of this need to get information
right away and can we have a sense of
urgency and that triggers a lot of those
interruptions think about all the
technologies that we have is
facilitating all those interruptions and
so if we assume that those interruptions
are going to stay then how do we cope
with this cognitively right so I'm going
to go back to this idea that what is the
brain in need for what prevents the
brain to transition to move from one
test to another to move from deep work
to deep work is this need for completion
and so what I found in my research is
that when we're in a position where we
are working on something we are
interrupted is incomplete we ask to move
we need to spend maybe a minute to
create what I called ready to resume
plan and so it's the same idea of
planning which is a different
implementation of it which is you stop
you say okay what is it that I was doing
where am I on my project what is it that
I want to do next when I return to it
so especially planning the return is
critical for the grant you feel like
okay I can let go because yes is not
finished but I have a plan that will
allow me to complete and so that sense
of completion is not a threatened as it
is when we just drop everything and
switch so this reduces the need to
resume plan what I've shown is that it
actually helps reduce a tension residue
on the next task and as a result
performance will not net next steps
actually increase tremendously I
tested it through different ways you
know it improves the quality of our
processing in terms of processing our
information people are able to pay more
attention it improves the quality of a
decision making that people engage in it
improves recall of information so they
have to recall information think that
they've read that's also is improved so
what was really interesting is it was a
less than a minute intervention and that
led to huge impact on attention and on
performance now what did you learn about
so if you're if you're writing something
for example and you take a brief break
to look at your email and respond to one
email and then you go right back to the
writing how long is the brain affected
in terms of limited focus after what
might be just 30 seconds to write an
email you know is it's actually it's
huge it's really surprising that how you
know I think it's counterintuitive for a
lot of people how just this very brief
interruption would actually affects you
when you come back right so so the issue
of switching in that case is you switch
to something else than what happens when
you come back well the brain basically
has to remember where is it that you
where in what kind of thoughts you can
influence your train of thoughts where
you were going and all of those things
by just switching away for a second then
it's going to take you a long time to
remember where you where to regain the
same level of concentration to remember
where you were going and so it doesn't
really mean obviously the longer the
interruption the harder that switched
back you know the harder it is to switch
back but but even small interruptions
actually are detrimental and so I think
that's where like if you're writing
something and you have to switch even if
it's just a few seconds if you cannot
put couple ideas of what you wanted to
write but even you know often time
people switch because they're kind of
like they don't know what to do next
they're not fully there or they're bored
or it's gonna hurt alright and so just
write like okay I need to write about X
I don't know how to but that's okay and
then you switch and then your return oh
yeah now I know it was about
yet that that seems to me to be one of
the most pernicious elements of the sort
of modern task-switching
availability of social media at anytime
that you want because at some point in
the past if you are writing something
and you have a very brief you know
momentary writer's block for example you
think through it and maybe in five
minutes you're past it but it's so easy
and it's so attractive to pick up your
phone and look at Facebook or look at
Twitter that even only 45 or 60 seconds
later you've now looked at you know 30
different posts and thought about 30
different things it actually seems like
it will hinder you from getting past
that writer's block in a way that maybe
just sitting there quietly for five
minutes would actually let you work
through the problem mm-hmm yes because
it makes you busy with something else
and you know very some research that
shows that when we let things incubate
we actually get new ideas and so it's
not that this is less about doing
something else but if that next task is
very pooling very engaging and even
social media to some extent is you don't
have it cut into space to actually
answer your friends while at the same
time think about the ideas that you were
trying to express that way you know or
the problem you're trying to solve and
so we're not getting we're not getting
much by switching in that case from a
pure creativity standpoint or problem
standing standpoint and so it but is
tempting it's easier it feels good right
yes I mean I guess given that it's just
our phones and the apps and the Internet
platforms that we use are designed to
keep our attention for as long as
possible how drastic do the measures
need to be that one uses or employees to
avoid those temptations and distractions
I mean should you be disconnecting your
computer from the internet if it's
possible well I mean it's just not
practical like when I'm preparing for my
show all of my source material is on the
internet so I can't literally disconnect
from the internet but I can put my phone
in the other room for example I'm sorry
oh that's right I agree if I think it's
you know the more you block what is
tempting you know so he's going to be
different things for different people
the I think the easier it is to not go
there when you've faced with a challenge
one thing that I for example do is I
will look at the time and I said okay
for the next 30 minutes I am not
touching anything right right now
there's something that I've that
happened to me that I think is
interesting and also relevant to this
kind of shaking out or checking other
devices for longest time I would put my
phone on vibrate so that I would not be
interrupted but then I realized that I
would check it because just in case the
pits cold cold for example just in case
someone leaked text me and I feel like
getting it to answer and I realized that
was actually forcing me to transition
versus if I have it on volume um then I
don't have to worry about it because I
will hear it if someone else to call me
now I have to tell you not a lot of
people call me during the day so wait so
that's also I I know that I can leave
that on volume and not be interrupted
that much but it completely removed all
my checking behaviors because I know if
someone else to reach me I will hear
them I don't have to worry about them
and so I allow myself them to help my
phone with me the other thing that I do
is very much like you I do a lot of in
terms of research I have to be on the
internet and I will go I'm going to tell
myself I am NOT going to check the news
I'm not going to take anything outside
of work you know even email for next two
hours and but that requires house
discipline but the interesting part of
it is I think it's discipline that we
can learn and we can train our attention
not to crave for those you know fast
gratification through social media for
example we can train our brain to stick
with what we're doing for a longer time
slowly so that's where I think there's
hope but it depends on what we are
willing to do and what what our goals
are yeah it definitely seems like
there's an element in this in which the
brain is sort of like a muscle that can
be strengthened so to speak to be better
at maintaining attention for longer
longer periods of time we have been
speaking with dr. Sophie Leroy who is an
associate professor at the University of
Washington Bothell School of Business
thanks so much for talking to me today
oh it was a pleasure thank you so much
for inviting me